and as luck would have it Patrick  Stewart has also done drag how beautiful  close-up is but now you have a drag  named of you oh yeah  patty loose - have you ever done back no  never go back oh come on you you savor  every drug that what is this Oh what  what is this  [Laughter]  [Applause]  whenever be good wherever I am around  the world digging a bath pick from that  like in Norway I wear a viking helmet  are in Canada where moose antlers and  that was Copenhagen of course a home of  this little mermaid so we don't being  for that I thought it's a girl wait he  told me that and the guy in the shop  that was costume shop recognized me so I  lost my bottle so I said to Jane you've  got a buyer right so Jane went up said  Oh what looking for a mermaid outfit and  he said this is it for you  then she went yes but bigger hiding in  it okay right and see with that and then  he was a good lead she paid for it and  he went someone's gonna have a good  weekend  [Applause]  [Music]  you